hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going back to Tokyo Avengers
and its final Saga to go over in depth
is super intriguing and intense three
deities Arc originally This was meant to
be the final part of the entire story
but like a majority of our marketers out
there Ken Wiki didn't end it and this
story continued on as it just didn't
feel like it could have finished after
the first conflict ceased hence why it's
turned into more of a Saga now than just
an arc now there are some things that I
really didn't enjoy happening throughout
this part of this story as I feel like
it's taken away from what it was
originally but this isn't a video where
I go over everything wrong with The Arc
and honestly this part of this story is
just jam-packed with some real fire
moments new people new organizations and
a heightened level of brutality all
throughout Earth honestly something that
I found more enjoyable in this Arc is
the fact that everyone is just slightly
older now and because of that it's
turned this original motorcycle-like
gang theme where they miss around doing
nothing more than kind of just fighting
each other and to more of a yakuza-like
organization where they are now involved
with like corrupt businesses and other
illegal activities but anyway enough
teasing hit that subscribe button if you
haven't already and let's get into the
three deities are from the final Saga of
Tokyo Avengers but just before we do get
into the video I want to thank the goats
themselves Gameloft for sponsoring this
video if you haven't heard much of
Empires as this dope immersive strategic
medieval game where people can rule
their own kingdom and Rise through
Conquest to become the mightiest Empire
of them all this game works on almost
every platform from Android to iOS into
even PC on this completely free to play
game you can choose between a variety of
different ways to move forward like
training your armies Gathering materials
through conquest or trading forming
strong alliances with other strong
players and friends to plot strategies
together or just like Mikey straight up
becoming a menace and the mightiest
Leader by yourself something that drove
me to like dive into this game more with
these really cool versus screams like I
love the Indian look at how the battle
is going along with the Strategic
options you get beforehand also this
November starting on the 15th March of
Empires is also dropping its biggest and
most exciting update of the Year
possibly ever introducing a brand new
faction which for all of my way babes
out there is this Japanese Shogun
faction this new update will buff the
game visually and submerge all of the
players in an authentic Japanese world
so make sure you go down below and use
my link in the description or the QR
code on screen to take advantage of the
guaranteed in-game VIP perks like 5000
free gold which is actually insane as
you otherwise start off with only 200
and start building your kingdom today
anyway again thanks to Gameloft for
sponsoring this video so after Mike he
literally tried to fly at the end of The
Last Arc takamichi gained the power of
plot and like ten thousand percent more
upper body strength after being shot and
still managed to catch a rocketing Mikey
as he fell towards the ground below then
on the verge of death ended up doing the
handshake respawn glitch so that
takamichi could save Mikey and try and
give the best possible future
deliverlights save his bro then live
happily with the check he's finally
saved anyway anyway starting off we find
ourselves with takamichi who's rushing
to school after his time leaped 10 years
back to the past once there he is
greeted by the four original boys
yamagishi Makoto takuya and akun who
remark on takamichi's unusual early
nurse continuing on to class along the
way he also encountered Sakai who had
leveled up the drip to the point he was
even unable to recognize him at first
after a short conversation between the
boys takamichi's mates take notice of
this randomly strange Behavior with him
and like honestly as someone who's been
reading the series for an entire year
now I've always wondered what they
actually held as takamichi acts like
when he isn't in his body and it's just
the normal child at him does he turn
into like a giga Chad and just forget
about all of his old friends or just
becoming Nobody Like We Only even get
the point of view through older
takamichi so I wonder what the true 14
year old or 16 year old takamichi is
actually like anyway after taking all of
this in takamichi immediately rushes to
find shifuyu who's chilling in a
classroom reading some manga looking up
Shifu remarks that takamichi is really
loud asking the reason for his abrupt
commotion remembering his interaction
with Mahi Tears start falling from
takamichi's eyes as he informs a shock
shifuyu of his unexpected turn from the
future with a new mission to save my key
yeah I keep forgetting this literally
happens within a few minutes of
takamichi almost dying I did was hanging
off a building just moments before being
in a school and being 10 years younger
so it's pretty crazy elsewhere probably
a similar time the bankroller big Coco
steps under the face of a man with a
sandal and reminds his opponent that the
Kanto Manji gang as the soul gang in
Tokyo nearby and sitting atop a rival
gang member sansu who I'm just gonna
like tell you right now is an absolute
complete waste of space anyway he
admires the nearby view commenting on
how their leader Mikey has defeated
countless men on his own standing there
surrounded by his defeated opponent
Mikey stares at his hand muttering so
you finally arrived takamichi skipping
back to the school after takamichi and
shifuyu processed the events shifuyu
tells takamichi the heavy Mikey as his
time traveling trigger will make it far
more difficult to go back to the future
to find out what Mikey is currently
doing they consult yamagishi because of
his big brain masterage of Japan's
delinquent gangs so I did say this
previously but it has now been two
entire years since the Tokyo Maji gang
expanded and because of this the power
structure of Tokyo's delinquent gangs
has changed completely the disband of
Toman which was the strongest group at
the time caused a Civil War as rival
gangs tried to gain power as he knew
strongest gang this period of conflict
was referred to as Tokyo sengoku period
which if you don't know is an actual
homage or relates to Japan's own sengoku
period also known as sengokujidai and
that translates to the Warring States
period this was a period in Japanese
history of like near-constant Civil War
and social upheaval from 1467 to 1615
and so just like in those historic
Japanese times and this new future
during Tokyo Revengers it now takes
place two years later three new gangs
Rose to power the first being the
rokuhada tandai Run by South Brahman
reinborne unknown Shady figure and the
Kanto Manji gang run by the Invincible
Mikey taking kamichi wonders why Mahi
disbanded Toman if he was just going to
turn around and make a new one but then
remembers the dark and positivity Mikey
has and attributes this as the reason
for his continued evil path shifuyu
tells takamichi that he is spacing out
before remarking that he must be
thinking of Mikey he then like the true
shed he is reminds takamichi that he has
to apologize to someone and that being
obviously kaina because he'd freaking
fixed everything with her and now he's
back in the past and could possibly have
ruin it all again after finding heiner
takamichi tearfully apologizes for
abandoning her and their wedding and
then subsequently dying because of Earth
dumbfounded Hina realizes that takamichi
has come back once again from the future
treasure Michi which is what am I
calling from now on because he's damn
messed up by coming back from his
perfect future tells hangner that he
realized that his mission will not end
until he saves Mikey reassuring him
though and like the best chick she is
heena says that even if takamichi makes
a mistake and causes a bad future she
will still support him no matter what as
he and shifuyu walked through their
school takamichi one is loud about how
he will defeat Mikey when she for you
tells not to blow us out random things
takamichi insists that he is serious
hearing this shifuyu instead suggests
that they should reunite Homan as they
need strength to take on my key just
then though Big Brother kahai shows up
and like oh my Lord when I first saw him
here I actually freaked out I full-on
thought it was by baji it just it took
me a moment to realize that it's not bad
it's a guy the new hairdo is just too
good anyways he joins the conversation
and asks what they're talking about but
before a nervous Tucker made she could
say anything her kairo Mark said they
both look free and tells the two he has
something to show them now arriving at a
lavish office takamichi doesn't
initially recognize the big chin himself
sitting behind the disk as Parr
introduces himself takamichi reacts in
surprise exclaiming that part got
released from juvenile detention at a
nearby table matsuya turns around and
asks takamichi if he's making a joke as
partying was released a while back now
also sitting nearby and looking like
just hella fresh there's which leaves
takamichi just blown away and delighted
at the fact that all of his friends are
still together hakai asks matsuya if
he's looking to bring to Rome will he
drip King himself replying that he's
thinking of renting a small design
studio as all of them talk takamichi
remembers that parchen and payan are
future business partners and as everyone
banters over the price and the features
of each room they want to rent shifuyu
turns to takamichi suggesting he recruit
them for his plan takamichi acknowledges
that this strength would be extremely
valuable and vital in defeating Mikey
but in the end he realizes something and
decides not to later on in on the subway
now her kind notes his admiration for
mitsuya par and payan as they continue
to move forward with their lives knowing
what his future holds though takamichi
reassures him telling nikai that he is
fine where he is as he'll make it big in
the future which is just hella wholesome
because of course our boy freaking knows
hakai was a baller in the past timeline
and then after hakai leaves them shifuyu
asks takamichi why didn't tell anyone
about his plan however the stubbornness
Manchild I can make she says that he
cannot bring himself to ask them as they
have all started going down their own
paths in life standing there shifuyu
wonders if there is anyone else they can
recruit but soon also realizes he's
running late for his part-time job as
takamichi watches shifuyu run off into
work he remembers shifu's future as a
pet store owner okay so I'm gonna cut
everything off now I don't know like a
little bit more about Japanese culture
in general at least I think I do I think
I know how Shifu ends up becoming the
owner of the store he most likely got
some kind of like lifetime contract
which is actually like a huge thing or
used to be a huge thing over in Japan up
until more recently like Nissan the car
company used to have thousands of
employees on similar lifetime contracts
anyways running through the streets
takamichi realizes that all of the old
Toma members now have their own personal
goals remembering that this is the
future Mikey promised to protect
takamichi decides that he cannot involve
anyone else in his plan resolving to
take Mikey on alone as he stands there
overlooking the harbor takamichi remarks
that he does doesn't know where to start
just then though his pocket starts to
vibrate as his phone rings with a call
from the big man himself draken or ryuji
kin which I always get wrong so I just
call him drakka no matter what pretty
much because you know you know me with
Japanese names skipping forward later to
that night takamichi arrives at the
infamous D in freaking D motorcycle shop
so everyone you know should know but
like for those of you who don't it's the
original store that Mikey's older
brother shinachiro Sano owned and now
it's fallen into the hands of big draken
after walking inside Dragon Gets up from
the bike he's working on which is
revealed to be Mikey's CB 250t and
apologizes for taking so long to fix it
saying that the party order took ages to
arrive startled takamichi realizes that
it's actually the bike Mikey had gifted
him skipping forward and now out on the
bike taking it for its first spin
takamichi relays his findings from the
prison to draken he says that his
mission this time is to save Mahi as he
always ends up saving him draken voices
his doubts though remarking that Mike is
the same ended completely Into Darkness
he says the mighty has changed and will
not hesitate to kill and murder
takamichi if he ever sees him again
takamichi confirms this by thinking back
on how he had literally just been shot
by the depressed future Mikey certainly
though the sound of another bike rings
out and a voice screams dragon's name
telling him to run this turns out to be
a bruised embedded up in new pay who has
been held with one hand by some jacked
up giant also riding on a bike well they
grin on his face the mysterious man
throws in your pay into the ear towards
the approaching Duo takamichi tries to
break the bike but can't stop in time
luckily though and your pay is just able
to miss the bike and land on the ground
the unknown individual then skids to a
stop calling for a knock turn which is a
musical composition that is inspired or
expressive like of the Night Dragon
takes a close look at him and recognizes
him to be the one and only South Toronto
the head representative of the rokuhara
tandai then as if it were pre-planned a
numerous number of bikers abruptly
arrive surrounding takamichi draken and
anupay as the three all stand their
surrounded Toronto casually strolls up
to dracon and asks him to join his gang
standing there takamichi remarks on the
vast number of gang members as well as
the Monstrous size of their leader after
Dragon confirms that Enya pay is pretty
beat up he reiterates back to South
Toronto that he would never join the
Roku had a tandai as he is completely
retired from gang life hearing this
Toronto punches dracon in the face
sitting him flying back onto the ground
torano angrily tells draken that he will
never forgive him if he decides to
retire attributing Tom and strength to
dragon's presence he continues to punch
Dragon repeatedly while exclaiming
musical terms takamichi still just like
standing there sees the assault and
finds it unfair that dragon has retired
from fighting which reckon now being
beaten on the ground Tarana tells him
that they have the same ideas as the
previous toeman to make a new era for
delinquents he attributes this as the
reason he even traveled to Tokyo in the
first place in order to defeat and
become the new era continuing he tells
draken they're retiring is unforgivable
explaining that the strongest retain
their position until they are defeated
then after declaring that this indeed is
a dog eat dog world Toronto presents
draken with an ultimatum either he bowed
down and work under him or submit and
die here in turning two and set it in
front of takamichi he addresses him as
toman's former division captain and
warns him that he is next as takamichi
begins to visually Panic a random
fodoras rokuhada tando member a synth
flying in front of him turning to the
perpetrator who turns out to be
brahman's number two in command to call
me Akashi honestly like all of Brahman
looks so damn freaking clean especially
to Comey like the dude looks so damn
drippy with it with this like cigarette
and all anyway anyway is it an annoyed
tarano tells him not to ruin the fun
it's revealed that Akashi has brought a
multitude of Brahman members with him
and now they have started fighting
against the other rokuharatano members
watching this from this tired and still
not having him move to like anywhere
takamichi begins to panic even more as
two of the three deities begin to face
off as rain starts to fall Akashi
completely and utterly blows everyone
Away by saying that his business here is
not to fight the rokuhara no but to
instead actually recruit takamichi
hanagaki into Brahman his proposal is
cut off by another Voice who turns out
to be kikucho see Nick Koko had joined
the rokuhada Akashi questions why
suggesting that Asana would have been
disappointed in him however kakucho
quickly replies asking him if he forgot
about shinichiro Sano which angers the
old school legend the tension between
the two heightens until kanji mochizuki
she only punching bag matarame ran and
rendo then all appear as current members
of the Roku had a tandai still like oh
my Lord takamichi are you gonna move
anywhere still standing there and
absolutely freaking out takamichi
realizes that all of the members of the
worst generation have arrived and the
Roku had a tandai is extremely dangerous
yet just standing there and chilling
like the man he is a casually remains
strangely calm he remarks on how nice it
is to be young casually asking someone
mysterious name sends you for
confirmation suddenly a hooded figure
darts into the center then proceeds to
absolutely rip an umbrella through the
air at torano however like the literal
giant selfers he manages to quickly
react in time and hits it aside however
though he does take too long to figure
out that the object thrawn was only an
umbrella when the hooded figure to jump
into the ear and easily deliver a heavy
ax kick directly to Toronto's Dome as
the mysterious delinquent flips back
onto the ground they tell they still
unmove takamichi to pick up his umbrella
after he does this and opens the
umbrella the seemingly mysterious person
says that they don't want to get weird
having seen the show of abilities
kakucho identifies this person as
brahman's Infamous leader as the
absolutely stunning leader takes off
your hood and announces the start of the
fight her name is revealed to be the one
and only kobaragi senju on like this
this moment was just too damn hype when
it initially dropped I remember like
half of the community including myself
being utterly confused for what seemed
like weeks at a time over whether or not
Sanju was actually a girl or a dude like
obviously it doesn't matter it's such a
trivial matter to like argue over but
it's too good to see Ken leading loose
and leading a dope ass female finally
take the role of a leader in his series
anyway anyway send you kawaragi and sell
Toronto stand in front of each other
well they let her acknowledging the
former at this moment xion like somehow
the man who stole Captain roll madarama
decides to intervene challenging senju
herself which is like why do you were
the boss in the very first getting in
the series it's like ultimate fodder
attacking a level 100 boss just retire
little man like even freaking send you
has no idea who he is which just makes
Shion embarrassed having to introduce
himself here however the Muppet is
instantly and completely knocked out in
a single punch by another new character
this newbie who turns out to be the
owner of a man casual arashi or Ben case
scold shion's neurodivergent ass for
ruining the good name of the black
dragon
being katel Sinju that in Mission today
is to recruit takamichi hanagaki and not
to start a fight hearing this kakucha
decides to move running towards BK and
smacking him back several meters before
like these Sly dog ears inviting
takamichi to join the rokuhara tandai
standing there to Comey is left
impressed by kokucho's strength however
and just like last time he immediately
calls forward a mysterious man who
silently and swiftly appears behind
kakucho the men insults kakucho claiming
that he would have been dead if he cared
enough being confused with all these new
people showing up and your pay
introduces them to takamichi as the
Living Legends and the former captains
of the original black dragons along with
Akashi who was known as the God of War
the three-fold alongside the revered one
shinichiro Sano as brahman's top brace
gather and you pay remarks that these
Living Legends have all gathered under
senju alluding to her dominating
strength big dragon breaks the moment by
dismissing these comments remarking the
black dragon's Founders he directly
challenges Tarana to finish the fight
that they just started remarking how
long it has been since he has felt this
excited as the standoff between the
rokuhada Tanda and Brahman causes a
traffic jam South remarks that he
intended to recruit dracon to defeat
Brahman however send you replies that
they also haven't shown up to fight no
instead they have only come to recruit
takamichi before the Kanto Manji gang
arrives hearing this Dragon announces
that he and takamichi will not be pushed
around by the two gangs when Dragon asks
takamichi for him to back him up on this
it triggers a promise that he made
inside of our boy's head to save Mikey
he announces that he's uninterested in
joining the gang either saying that his
sole goal is to defeat Mikey annoyed
South screams at him asking if he wishes
to intervene with the role of the three
deities which is a game related back to
the Warring States period and how the
power struggle there resulted in a
complete standstill anyone else
interfering would cause like all-out war
and one power to completely take over
suddenly Dragon lunges itself and smacks
him in the face sending the giant flying
back he tells self that he will have to
go through him to get to takamichi
seeing that he is ready for the second
round of the fight however just as South
announces his Mutual eagerness to fight
the sound of police sirens approach
interrupting them which is typical the
freaking Ops ruining the fun as everyone
begins getting it from the cops self
tells dragon that they'll have to face
off next time seeing thus takamichi
Smiles in relief knows him that dragon
has not changed in the last two years
and is still loyal to Toman yet as he
Retreats with Brahman Akashi approaches
draken and silently apologizes to him
for not intervening having seen his
interaction takamichi has left slightly
confused wondering about akashi's
possible relation to draken skipping
forward now and riding backwards reckon
takamichi apologizes for abruptly
screaming out his intentions in front of
everyone hearing this Dragon Chuckles to
himself as he remarks that it was very
normal of him to do so takamichi replies
that he's happy to see that Dragon
hasn't changed much either however
Dragon grow serious and as he begins
telling takamichi that he has something
to confess going on to reveal that he in
fact has already joined Brahman after
Dragon divulges his relation with
Brahman the two soon arrived back at the
bike shop as the new pay helps takamichi
draw from the rain upstairs takamichi
remarks that it's been a difficult day
noting that Dragon didn't come inside
yet takamichi inquires about his
whereabouts with inupay saying that he's
currently outside with Brahman probably
discussing takamichi as takamichi
prepares to leave and you pay caution to
him saying that he's worried about
draken he notes that Brahman is rumored
to be more like the Yakuza instead of a
delinquent biker gang warning takamichi
to be careful skipping outside we find
Drake and absolutely pissed off holding
Akashi against the wall angrily
exclaiming that he just doesn't listen
he tells the Comey that takamichi's
recruitment is prohibited along with any
other former Toman members in that
moment though takamichi arrives and
immediately demands an explanation as to
what's going on standing nearby still
just chilling under the umbrella Sindhu
says that draken is trying to bring back
Mikey but the Brahman organization wants
to defeat Mikey's new cartoon Manji gang
so due to the similarities in both of
their missions they have decided to work
together for now addressing takamichi
Akashi says that he admired Thomas goals
of creating a new era for delinquents
however now Mikey's new group has
utterly strayed from those ideals and no
longer has any ambition Akashi products
that if Mahi continues on this path he
will become a terrible person so he
states that brahman's existence is a way
of countering this outcome since you
think comments on takamichi's speech
earlier saying that his ambition would
be well used in Brahman and invites him
to join if he ever desires upon hearing
this takamichi realizes that although he
was unsuccessful in recruiting old Homan
members utilizing other gangs against
Mikey may be a possible solution in
actually defeating him because damn we
all gotta face facts here I don't think
takamichi is ever winning in a
hand-to-hand fight with Mahi the dude is
just something else when it comes to
like fights obviously after sinju's
offer Dragon angrily interrupts and this
time threatens to become brahman's enemy
a takamichi becomes involved however
since she was utterly unfazed and
instead asks if he plans to fight them
here and now shocked with a sudden
escalation takamishi interrupts them
while reminding himself that the future
will not change if he continues to Stand
By and Watch and to dragon's shock he
decides to join Brahman which is like
finally man it was just so Random seeing
takamichi stand around during the entire
conflict that happened beforehand
instead of actually doing something made
it seem like we were back at square one
with timido trash and meet you anyway
anyway before leaving Akashi reminds
draken of brahman's ultimate goal of
defeating the kantomanji gang but says
that he himself doesn't want to fight
Mikey which is why he recruited Mikey's
old friends for that exact purpose as
Sinju puts down the umbrella noting that
it's finally stopped raining dragon's
eyes explaining that they share a common
goal with Brahman but that is the only
reason for their cooperation shaking
hands draken welcomes takamichi into
Brahman but not before reminding him
that this sole reason for the alliance
is to bring Mikey back standing there
with his usual stoic demeanor takamichi
vows to stop Mikey from continuing down
the wrong path
as Dragon agrees since you intervene
seeing that it's decided and gives him
the umbrella telling takamichi that from
now on here's going to be her gopher
which obviously just leaves him
absolutely confused Sinju then orders
takamichi to meet with him tomorrow and
Harajuku at 3pm smiling Akashi tells
takamichi to just be utterly prepared as
xinju has become interested in him which
is super confusing like I remember when
these chapters were initially releasing
and everyone was like yo what's going on
right now who's who is this person it
was super intriguing just to see how the
landscape had completely changed from
The Last Arc during team jiku anyway
skipping forward now to the next day
takamichi arrives in Harajuku as
directed there a voice behind him
apologizes for the weight turning around
takamichi's surprise to see a girl who
eerily resembles xinju the girl
announces that she's going shopping
telling takamichi to carry her
belongings obviously though our boy is
just utterly shocked at the realization
that he's having and just blankly steers
eduer confused confused herself with
takamichi's reaction since you remind
him of his prior promise to mate still
in shock takamichi finally clicks and
exclaims that she is a girl which annoys
her as she states that he's being too
loud still unsure takamichi tries
confirming if she's brahman's leader
however since you just leaves him there
and begins on a shopping trip
skipping forward into the shopping trip
and through most of the because
who actually cares about half of the
stuff that happens here takamichi asks
Sinju about her relationship with Akashi
noting this significant age difference
surprisingly since you then reveals that
he's actually her older brother and her
real name is Akashi as well continuing
with her family explanation she mentions
there is a format home and Captain
takamichi should also know harichiro
sanzu the middle Sublime which is just
like freaking massive sound to a
character who hasn't played like any
part in the story so far just showing up
and becoming the super mysterious dude
all of a sudden as takumichi stands
there shocked trying to process the
information since you've bursts out of
the dressing room exclaiming that she
and her siblings are known to be
mysterious intrigued takamichi asks if
sansu is in Brahman as well but she says
that he isn't instead she says that
Sanju is not interested in her in fact
he joined the kantumanji gang despite
her strength and Akashi supporting her
cause shocked takamichi remembers his
encounter with sansu and the prison
timeline you know the old Mikey jumper
timeline and concludes that the Kanto
Manji gang will surely become bontin and
the future later on as takamichi
arranges the countless purchase the
senji made he thinks about sinju's
family realizing that Sansa will be an
important factor in his mission stopping
by an ice cream vending machine
takamichi recommends Sinju the chocolate
mint flavor although she is initially
doubtful about it she is quickly
delighted by the harmony of the flavors
after finishing the ice creams and
preparing to leave send you smiles and
thanks takamichi for the fun day
together then after waving goodbye
takamichi jokingly asks her how long
she's going to keep the ice cream stick
in her hand Twitchy says she wants to
eat choco mint again with takamichi
smiling takamuchi promises to buy some
for her next time and offers to throw
away her rubbish however in a moment it
would seem normal to anyone else since
you tosses the stick towards takamichi
and as it lands in his hand it triggers
some sort of memory a tearful one in
which sends you lays in the arms of
takamichi dying a as she slowly
approaches death she tells him that he
kept his promise skipping forward and
still absolutely confused over the
vision he had had before takamichi
Ponders his thoughts of send you
supposed final moments just then draken
tells takamichi to stop spacing out as
he comes back to reality takamichi
realizes where he is and remarks on the
Nostalgia of visiting dragon's home in
Shibuya jerkin explains that living and
helping at the brothel gives him the
financial stability that his bike shop
cannot yet provide estacamichi presses
the elevator button another of these
weird visualizations start where he
finds a dark blood-like stain going up
his torso but as he blinks again out of
pure horror he instantly sees that now
his shirt has returned to normal draken
who can obviously say that takamichi is
going through some sort of panic
inquires about his behavior but
takamichi says it's nothing before
wondering to himself what these Visions
could possibly mean and the brothel
draken introduces the boss to takamichi
someone who regards as a parental figure
after takamichi sees hi Dragon laid him
down the hall of the brothel pastly
beautiful waifu who bombard him with
various questions when tokamichi asks if
the girls there are the same ones as
when he visited last time jaquin replies
that they are not as the harsh world is
ever-changing which is actually kind of
sad it's obviously this is the life that
Dragon would have got used to over time
with girls who tried acting like
motherly figures just disappearing
without him initially even knowing why I
wanted to say the dude who raised him
was seemed like an absolute G just
before because man's dressed up in the
finest clothing and looks like one but
we've got to face the facts that a
brothel probably isn't the best place
for a child to develop so it's a miracle
dragon is growing into the absolute goat
of a gentleman that he is today and
draken's now larger room takamichi
excitedly inspects dragon's bulletin
noting the pictures of himself tomin and
of course Emer thinking of her Dragon
says that she appears in his dreams
telling him to save Mikey sitting there
he explains that he just can't abandoned
my key which causes takamichi to realize
the true motivation behind Shrek and
joining Brahman dracon then asks about
how much his future self is currently
doing to which takamichi describes
Mikey's thin depressed sleep deprived
and deranged appearance as well as his
involvement in the criminal organization
bontin he explains that Mikey could not
suppress his dark and positivity however
his friends and Hina are living happily
takumichi recalls Mikey's promise two
years earlier to protect his friends and
Hannah's Futures with everyone living a
happy life it's obvious to him now that
Mikey has fulfilled his promise but now
because of that he's the only one living
in Missouri hearing this information
dracon remarks that Mikey was already
thinking about the future two years ago
instantly after takamichi had traveled
back he goes on to say how Mikey had
beaten him mitsuya Shifu and payan all
up causing them to shake with fear and
grow over time to despise him still
sitting down tracking processes the idea
of the dark and positivity and he knows
that their lives have indeed improved
with Mikey's absence yet he speculates
that Mikey distancing and villainizing
himself was really to fulfill his
promise to takamichi smiling Dragon
remarks that what he's doing now isn't
wrong skipping slightly forward and
walking down the hall now Joker reminds
takamichi that the future will have
already changed as he has joined Brahman
and in the original timeline he hadn't
although they don't know the coming
event both Drake and takamiji swear that
they are going to bring back Mikey
themselves just then one of the girls
bumps into takamichi though interrupting
the conversation and spilling tomato
juice onto his shirt as Dragon pokes fun
at the juices bloodluck appearance
takamichi once again snaps into a
momentary days as he sees blood on his
hands and he starts to wonder if he can
actually foresee the future later the
next day we find senju and takumi in a
meeting with a businessman who welcomes
brahman's involvement with their
business he explains that many companies
these days are using gangs as a form of
protection sitting there since you
reluctantly agrees to help but after the
businessman happily thanks her she
suddenly lashes out threatening to
sabotage his business if the company
involves itself in prostitution which
leads the older men terrified in
apologizing which makes sense you know
like what kind of trick or honesty
anyone these days would want to force
anyone into prostitution so it makes
perfect sense for Sinju to go over and
above to protect all of her like fellow
jerks anyway as they leave the area and
exhausted Akashi size reminding senju
that the man is the customer since you
understands this and doesn't expect
business to be exactly ethical but says
brahman's potential involvement and that
line of work angers her Akashi responds
by Notting the difference between an
adult and a kid stating that it's the
ability to prevent emotions from
crowding one's judgment or decisions
going on to say that that's exactly what
Mikey does over without one of the
world's most durable punching bags
Dragon leads him to brahman's next
meeting he remarks on the numality of
the place and non-descript building with
cameras and an electronic door lock as
he walks in a shot Tucker makes you
finds himself at the top of a huge
indoor fighting ring Dragon explains to
him that this is B1 brahman's
underground fighting ring they
coordinate and televise nightly matches
for the rich who bit on the fights here
B1 created a gang of strong Fighters
which over time has formed into Brahman
suddenly senju arrives at the top of the
flight of stairs ordering the cameras
off and announcing their meeting's
commencement honestly she looks too damn
clean here but the fit is absolutely
fire and have noticed the designs on
each of the uniforms also vary from each
Brahman captains so I'm wondering if
there is any specific meaning behind
that that's been revealed in the future
now or is it just a design choice that
Ken waikoui decided to go with but
anyways as she enters walking down the
steps of the Arena then take a new place
in the center of the Ring causing
brahma's chance to stop instantly she
then introduces the group's newest
member that being takamichi hanagaki and
ordering him to join her in the arena
send you lists takamichi's numerous
accomplishments in the gang world
including the Battle of August the 3rd
bloody Halloween the Christmas conflict
the Kanto incident and his status as
toman's first division Captain and the
current black dragons leader hand in
takamichi a Brahman uniform since you
welcomes him into the gang stating that
this will be his uniform from today then
turns and announces her intention to
fight both the Kanto manjikang and the
rokuhara tandai next week on the 14th of
July declaring the date as the battle of
the three deities chucking on this brand
new uniform which by the way looks too
damn good with a black dragons writing
on each arm anyways as he Chucks on his
uniform he finally anticipates seeing
Mikey and the coming conflict later in
the night as takamichi sits there
wondering about what's going on inside
senju's head a people randomly strikes
his window looking outside he finds her
obviously going to prove that she's a
complete another psycho but I don't know
what she's actually doing but she
immediately invites him out for a date
at like 10 pm at night which just
confuses the hell out of takamichi but
you know anyway takamichi happily agrees
to go out on this date with her out on
the date now since you brings takamichi
to an amusement park as they enter the
park since he was all struck by the
dazzling light adding that she has not
been here since the sixth grade when
takamichi asks why she is still cleared
a new Brahman uniform since you
explained that the uniform is easier to
move around in now side by side on the
roller coaster since you tell takamichi
her plan for next week during the
conflict he and dracon will face Mikey
and the Kanto Manji gang while she and
Akashi will defeat the rokuhadatan die
she is confident in her strength
explaining that she could even take on
both gangs alone just as he expresses
her desire to become Japan's top
delinquent a roller coaster drops much
to takamichi's Terror xinju like still
unfazed by it all continues explaining
her plan of expanding Brahman however
she says that Akashi has changed and
instead of just making Brahma stronger
he is fixated on growing Brahma now
oblivious as the takamichi dying
literally right next to her on the
roller coaster since you explains that
the gang's expansion will lead to the
involvement of unhappy people but that's
why she wants to solve things quickly
with the three deities before the group
grows after they finish the ride Cindy
notices a tanzaku which for all my weebs
out there are tanzaku which of 100 said
wrong but like it visually shows here
means paper or a thin slice of wood
which is cut into strips and then hung
on bamboo people like these days will
often write them as sort of like a
personal wish to themselves but anyway
enough of that now that you get off it
pairing it has wished to defeat Mikey
sends you playfully remarks so that
that's boring and simple she then
reveals her wish to takamichi which is a
promise to protect hanagaki as takamichi
reflects on send you straightforwardness
she confesses to him that this is a
first for her before completely and
utterly friend zoning him asking if he
would like to be friends with her which
is good though because we can't be
having seen you come in here who's
awesome and they're missing up the damn
previous 200 chapters that takamichi had
just worked for anyway anyway smiling
takamichi agrees and Promises to protect
senju in return although since you
jokingly says that she's strong enough
already they still shake hands in
agreement however as the hands touch
takamichi is suddenly throwing into
another vision of an injured since you
dying in his arms again she smiles
telling takamichi that she has kept her
promise skipping through it more he
knows notices that this time the vision
is clearer and depicting the setting of
a freaking amusement park what takamichi
thinks he stands there shocked thinking
about the visions that he just had while
since you remarks that it has just begun
to rain flashing over to the bike shop
Jack and peers outside to comment on the
summer rain when suddenly and you pay
rides up skidding in front of the door
he then instantly reveals to a confused
dragon that the Roku had a tandai is
currently on its way to attack takamichi
meanwhile at the amusement park a senju
runs for cover from the rain takamichi
tries pacing together the meaning of his
Visions not in his current setting in
the amusement park the rain in sinju's
promise hit the doses that these Visions
are ones of the days approaching events
skipping slightly forward and now in a
cafe Sinju and takamichi wait out the
rain after Sinju shoots off to the
bathroom takamichi gets lost in his
thoughts wondering what to do in case's
future Visions become reality he then
recalls a vision of Sinju bleeding from
the kid and dying and then realizing
that Sinju is currently in the restroom
he rushes off to find her scolding
himself for leaving her alone under the
current circumstances just as he reaches
the restrooms takamichi sees the tanzaku
with sinju's promise to protect him as
he stands there looking at it he comes
to a realization however as he looks to
the side he sees a large group of hooded
masked men approaching him they ask of
his takamichi which causes them to
realize they aren't even targeting Sinju
but in fact him one of them talks to the
other asking are they really going to do
this to which the other man reassures
him stating that it is the only way for
small fries to climb up the ladder
another man tries protesting however the
man pulls out a gun responding that
South will understand his actions by the
way for those of you who don't realize
this or even watched a previous video of
mine in the past the person holding the
gun isn't just like a random photo dude
but is in fact choji who in the past was
a former captain of Valhalla and one of
kisaki's little Gomes so obviously he's
trying to make his way back up through
the Roku harder now as takamichi steers
at the barrel of the gun he pieces
together the meaning of his Visions
since you'll die trying to protect him
here suddenly behind him since you
appears rushing up trying to save him
scared of the approaching future
takamichi screams with her to stay back
while at the same time the man grips his
gun warning takamichi to not move also
however takamichi ignores the father
fall and runs towards Sanju telling her
to not come near him as he jumps
directly in front of her a few gunshots
ring out and with tokimichi seemingly
collapsed atop Sinju choji thinks he
successfully killed him and begins
laughing like a madman yet as per every
fodder character he somehow missed every
single bullet and takamichi Rises
completely unscathed as Sinju looks up
at him in Surprise takamichi asks if
she's alright then seeing that she is he
tells her he cannot let her die standing
behind them though with the guns still
drawn toji screams at takamichi asking
him how he managed to dodge the bullets
takamichi himself realizing that there
isn't any Escape braces for the bullets
but as the gun rings out he is taken by
surprise when all of a sudden the gun is
sent flying through the air and
clattering to the ground turning he then
sees the one and freaking only big
draken who has managed to somehow
intervene and knocked out choji as
Dragon ensures the safety of his boy and
Sinju takamichi's stammers in relief at
the changing events elsewhere at a
similar time Mikey overlooks the Rainy
City behind him Coco asks him what's up
with Mikey replying that it's pouring
and he has a bad feeling so we got
cryptic Mikey this Arc boys man is
actually speaking in tongues the second
time we've seen him and he's depressed
and speaking in tongues already
meanwhile the noise of gunshots
reverberates around the amusement park
scattering away all of the civilians
back in the standoff draken approaches
the men from The rokuhada tandai Who end
up fleeing the terror still shocked at
dragon's sudden arrival takamichi thanks
him for saving him and seeing you after
takamichi confirms that xinji was
actually unharmed he asks why and how
Dragon knew to show up to which he
explains the inyipei had heard that
rokuata tandai was targeting takamichi
and alluded him to it which you know has
like always interested me like where
exactly did anybody hear this and who
from was it an overheard conversation
while he was out spying on people in
secret or was he perhaps even betraying
the boys anyways anyways as takamichi
stands surprised at his targeting by a
lower level rokuhada dracon Smiles
reminding him of his revered status in
the delinquent World growing serious
Drake and Ed said the conflict between
the three deities may not be as simple
as their delinquent conflicts in the
past he explains that everyone's eyes
have changed and these gangs are now
involved with unethical businesses which
invest into the gangs after takamichi 1
is allowed about the future dragon
speculates that Mikey had possibly
protected all of this standing there
side by side takamichi confides in his
closest friend and tells him that he can
now foresee future events because of
what dragon's done today he's prevented
a horrible future from occurring he
explains his visions of send you dying
and thanks dracon for helping him change
the future taking all of this in Dragon
smiles and says that that's good so
suddenly send you breaks them from the
conversation and reminds them that they
need to leave the premises as the police
will surely show up soon quickly the two
run off but as takamichi runs behind
senju he notices draken Still Standing
his back turned like he hasn't moved
from the moment he kicked the gun
abruptly Dragon slightly turns and tells
takamichi to relay a message to Mikey
don't cause too much trouble confused
takamichi tells Dragon to tell Mikey
himself but before takamichi can even
finish his sentence the goat himself
collapses to the floor having sustained
three gunshot wounds to the chest lying
there in the warm summer rain as his
blood pours from his body he says that
this is as far as he goes as he slides
in and out of Consciousness jerkin notes
has an ability to hear move or even see
clearly finding a friend to takamichi
over him hanakaki informs draken that he
is called an ambulance and since he was
already looking for help he tries his
best to reassure dragon with a smile but
Dragon notices the pain flowing was
clinched first aloud Dragon says that he
gets it he is dying upon hearing these
words takamichi tears up and tries to
insist that he isn't dying and that
things will be fine by tomorrow however
as he asks for reassurance from him
Dragon steers into the reigning sky and
prepares for his impending death while
the faint grin he tells takamichi to not
blame himself he explains that this
decision here to protect takamichi was
one of his own and not a consequence of
takamichi's time leaps going on big
dragon like the king he is says that
because of the life takamiji gave him
he'd gladly laid down and sacrificed his
own life to save takamichi after
assuring a crying takamichi that he
understands this Dragon falls into eight
days and reminisces on his elementary
school days where he would lose so many
fights against older kids following his
defeat Dragon would crawl onto the
ground and look up into the sky just
like he is now he says looking into the
sky grounded him and provided pace which
taken she understands however Dragon
adds that Mikey doesn't know about the
sky and is never being defeated which
must have grown to become a burden for
him while his words growing more
strained draken explains the love that
he had towards his best friend the way
that he shouldered everything himself
but still kept moving forward admired
him choking on his blood now Dragon says
that that's why he wishes he could have
helped mahimura and asks takamichi for
one final favor one that he considers
lame with tears in his eyes Dragon asks
takamichi to take care of my key to
which takamichi promises to do so after
the ambulance arrives takamichi rushes
over as the paramedics load dracon into
the ambulance as his mind slowly Fades
to Black Dragon thinks back to the 1st
of January 2005 when he and all of the
boys didn't have a care in the world
back then the Toman leaders would ride
around on their bikes and head to the
beach to celebrate the new year after
the group there go over all of their
recent conflicts they all agree that
Toman is getting bigger and stronger due
to Mikey's strength Dragon adds that
Mikey who is currently riding ahead of
them is the Invincible face of tommen
interrupting their thoughts though Mikey
urges them to ride faster as they may
miss the sunrise skipping forward to 4am
now the group arrives at the beach where
they Marvel at the Starry Sky to combat
the cold weather bhaji order shifuyu and
her Kai to buy something from the
convenience store which they head off to
do at the same time Dragon starts
running along the beach joined by
matsuya baji pachin paiyan and smiley
it's explained why they're all messied
around that Mojo the squad 5 Captain
didn't want to take the car out and is
too lazy to do so which is kind of funny
because I swear he's still like too
young to even drive at this point in the
series but yeah anyway by the time hakai
and shifuyu return the sun has begun to
rise and all of the captains have tied
out from the Run Dragon spots Mikey over
at the pier watching the sunrise as he
approaches his boy from behind pause the
other members see in or at the beauty of
the Rising Sun marketing places his palm
above the sun and clinches it grasping
the sun he tells dragon that he's going
to seize this world and standing by his
side like always Dragon agrees saying
that in this year they will conquer the
whole country which you know like Mikey
plays in his palm on the sun and
clichina is a big big homage or like
foreshadowing to Mahi you know like
grabbing all of Japan and conquering
Japan because you know the Rising Sun
back in reality now as he remembers that
morning Dragon weeps remarking that his
final memories are indeed with Toman
after all then as her life finally Fades
he tells Emma that he is on his way to
her visualizing their Spirits reuniting
as he dies
over at The rokuhara tando Hideout which
looks like some sort of bar all of the
top executive's watch itself beats the
absolute out of the perpetrators of
dragon's death although South curses the
mean for their extreme actions he grins
adding that they had to do it didn't
they back in the parking lot send you
watches as takamichi recalls the moments
prior he'd frantically asked the
paramedics of draken's condition but
sadly they informed him that he was
already gone though Sinju calls out to
takamichi several times she fails to
bring him out of his catatonic state
which is you know so sad I remember when
this moment first happened and it was
like a sealment on Dragon's death fight
yeah the last chapter him going away
with Emma maybe he could have come back
if like the paramedics restarted his
heart or something but no this
absolutely sealed his death right here
with a paramedic saying that it was
already gone anyway just then Akashi
arrives behind them after confirming
that the Roku had a tandai perpetrated
dragon's death who swears Revenge
ordering Ben K to gather the rest of
Brahman here in akashi's plans
sensuously shocked saying that they
could not act today pested each other
who are into Comey erupt into an
argument about the best course of action
Akashi angrily declares the goals have
changed from a super childish brawl to a
battle to the death since you're a torts
though trying to say that he's wrong
while all the while takamichi remains in
his shaken State unable to move or
process the events however to add to the
already messed up situation South
suddenly arrives in the parking lot
peaking hanagaki's dulled mind after he
taunts draken's death he screams at
takomi to start this Armageddon twitch
to Comey screams back that he is going
to end this now yet once again another
Interruption Rings throughout the ear as
the distinct sound of a motorcycle
quickly approaches arriving alone at the
scene we find a somber emotionless Mikey
seeing him a stun takamichi shakily
utters his estranged friend's name soon
after this the rest of the kantoomanji
gang ride up behind their leader a as
the three gangs face each other South
into Comey prepare to fight for takomi
declaring the battle in Dragon's honor
self loudly proclaims the start of the
war of the three deities meanwhile the
megalomaniac sansu orders the kantumanji
gang to kill everyone boom so officially
the big battle of the three deities
begins as utter chaos starts to envelop
the area takomi mixes to staying for the
katobanji gang clear accusing them of
abandoning dracon standing nearby to
commit she watches in horror while Sinju
tries to raise him with Brahman telling
them to not allow their emotions to
overwhelm them but to no avail from a
distance Maki and Coco watch the
developing situation koku remarks his
surprise and Mikey's complete an action
in the fight asking him if he even cares
about it hearing this and probably not
even realizing that draken has died at
this point unless you know like
overheard Akashi yelling Marky appears
confused about what Coco could be
referring to South calls for his top
fighters to forget about the Kanto Manji
gang and take out Brahmin first
meanwhile Akashi fearlessly fought his
way towards South literally knocking out
dozens of rokuhara tandai members from
these Sidelines Sinju screamed little
brother to get a hold of himself and
rushes in in an attempt to try and stop
him but wakasu stops her first telling
her to not get involved as this fight is
nothing like she's been a part of before
he reminds send you of the gravity of
the situation as it has become fatal
resulting in draken's death then before
joining the fight with the muscle man
himself being K wakasa tells takamichi
to take care of Sinju referring to her
as brahman's Princess having milked a
few more fodder falls on his way to
South to Comey demands to know why he
killed draken revealing that it was
never a formal member of Brahman and
should have killed him instead as he
shout two rokuhara members restrain
Akashi selthin prepares to punch the
defenseless man however just before he
connects BK suddenly appears blocking
his strike and punching to Comey back he
remarks that self's punch is
surprisingly weak despite his size then
again instantly behind him wakasa leaps
through the air looking like he's got
some sort of ninjutsu or something and
lands a perfect kick to South Stone as
wakasa slides across the ground he tells
self that he's now fighting with
brahman's strongest not faced by this
though self-enthusiastically declares
his excitement to face the first
generation of the black dragons and not
gonna lie I'm I'm pretty sure that makes
these guys like 26 to 28 years old or in
that kind of age range in comparison to
most of the other people around which
are still miners aged like 16 to 19.
it's honestly the most random Dynamic
when you think about it like that like
why is their 30 year olds hanging out
and fighting against kids anyways it's
the massive battle between the three
games and shoes kakutu fights his way
through Mikey's gang in an attempt to
confront him yet as more Kanto members
Rush towards him he wonders why Mikey
isn't making any kind of move himself
like the rat he is sansu takes advantage
of the Ambush on kikucho swinging his
favorite pipe over his head and knocking
him to the floor he then goes to taunt
kakucho but from behind him the sexy ass
ran shows up and smashes sanzu over the
face with his own weapon throughout the
battlefield various Kanto members react
in Terror at the sheer power of the s62
generation meanwhile as all of the boys
face off South is extremely impressed
commenting that the greatest Duo have
indeed lived up to their name and
defeated over a hundred of rokuhada
tandai's members
as takamichi who yes is still like
standing there in the same spot like in
a different spot from when you know the
dragon fight was going on but still the
same spot as this fight what does the
monolith's face off while Sinju explains
to him their history back in the day
before even the formation of the black
dragons those two divided the entire
Kanto region with their gangs bin K LED
Ragnarok and we're not talking about the
trash Netflix adaptation no this here is
the freaking massive 600 member Gang
located in Western Kanto which by the
way is a bigger size than like any game
we've seen so far in the series Ragnarok
was considered Japan's largest gang and
Ben K was given the nickname redcliffe
due to him wearing the blood of his
defeated enemies on the opposite side
Coco Ringo like my pronunciation of
these has got to be so bad like so white
person of me form the 12 smaller gangs
all under the leadership of the white
leopard better known as emuashi wakasa
these two groups engaged in numerous
conflicts which never resulted in Pace
until a previously unknown shinichiro
United them forming the original black
dragons since you say that according to
Akashi they are without a doubt Japan's
toughest Brawlers back with the
so-called strongest Duo being cases that
he wanted to preserve his strength for
later and he battle against Mikey but
now they have no choice but to fight
opposite them South screams like a
freaking mad man doing his random
musical and taunting them which
causes Ben K and mukasa to quickly Dart
him towards him of course though in that
usual like clickbait anime style we
don't even continue with the fight here
now instead we find ourselves now in a
flashback going over the life of the
maniacal self who was born with the name
anami torano gluing that South grew up
in Rio de Janeiro of all places with
this beard written mother and the reason
for like his crazy musical outbursts are
Judah was only childhood toy being an
old piano which is you know pretty deep
during his life over in Rio a baller in
complete G named Dino functioned as his
mother's caregiver and a surrogate
father he introduced her Toronto to
Brazil's gang life at the extremely
early age of five pretty much Dino
groomed Toronto into violence by
ordering him to shoot men he considered
his enemies and after Toronto's success
Dino gave him his current nickname self
however at 12 something happened causing
him to snap and kill Dino or Dino I just
realized by basing him to death which is
you know like crazy dude dude was a 12
year old beating down on the monster of
a human that was Dino anyway skipping
forward two years a rival gang raided
South's home and murdered his mother
then with both parental figures dead
South decided to move back to Japan
where his grandparents lived yet while
he was there he continued his usual
disruptive self and self restarted his
gang activity there eventually Landing
himself in juvenile detention after some
time and attention he encounters the
recently incarcerated s62 generation
members and here's of their involvement
during the Kanto Uprising from this
South concludes that if he defeats them
he can become kanto's top gangster eager
to build his own era South easily
defeats ran rendo Shion mucho and mochi
around a year later in 2007 after South
is released from detention here
alongside the hatani brothers Mochi and
xion created the Roku had a tandai while
talking with ran South expressed his
desire to recruit kocho into the
rokuharatan Dai to which Ryan replies
that kokucho will not listen to him as
he was only a part of tinjiku to start
with because of izana laughing in reply
South assures ran that he's good at
negotiating flashing forward we find
that the so-called negotiation is more
or less a Beatdown one where he brutally
beats kikucho in an Alleyway as he lays
on the ground beaten and bruised kikuchu
admits his defeat to a grinning
unparalleled self back in reality now
where castle and Bin K both panned as
they slowly begin to Tire against South
noticing their fatigue Toronto taunts
them asking if they're already tired
then from over the other side of the
battle kakucho glances over as the black
dragon's strongest Duo faced off he
concludes that no matter how strong they
are South will emerge Victorious as he
is a man of extreme violence instantly
the two sides Rush towards each other
with a castle dodging South's fist then
using his momentum he lifts his leg and
flicks it directly into South's head
Landing a powerful Kirk still flowing
with that sexy Japanese Aura of his he
turns swiftly in mid-air before striking
South with a flurry of additional kicks
and quick succession still somehow
standing South barely has time to
recover before bnk barrels towards him
with a roar while riding his punch being
heading hits South across his big ass
head sitting him tumbling across the
concrete Still Standing as Spectators
just like our boy takamichi koku asks
Mikey if he is happy with the battle's
outcome as he predicts brahman's Victory
is quickly approaching however the even
more intriguing Mikey Christians Coco's
prediction skipping back south abruptly
rises from the floor surprising the
strongest Duo as he takes off his
uniform looking like absolutely jacked
he literally starts going on that
typical evil and Tech childhood spiel
about their messed up life so like you
know for a fact that this man is about
to level the freaking Earth he reveals
to the shocked Spectators the killing of
his father figure at the age of 12. the
death of his mother from a gang raid on
his place and how he obtained these
scars although he nearly died from gang
violence South explains that he cannot
stop his urges hearing this and standing
across from him takamichi is immediately
reminded of Mikey's dark impulses
looking like he's slowly growing taller
South Towers above okasa and Bin K and
ridicules the possibility that he could
ever lose to them instead he claims that
this makes him even more violent then in
an instant self brutally pummels both
with Casa and Bin K over the head
standing above their beaten barely
conscious bodies looking just toe damn
malevolent South announces his love of
violence then calling out to Mikey he
implies that he understands behind self
send you shout making of Prisons known
then after walking forward to confront
the nutter she apologizes to wakasa for
intervening but states that she could
not sit back idly and watch so instead
she'll deal with him by herself skipping
away from the main tassel for a bit we
see that the big battle between the
three deities has lived hardly anyone
standing sansu pants exhausted as he
faces off against Ryan again over the
other side of the area with countless
defeated members behind him kakutra
finally reaches Mikey as Mikey stands
there unresponsive he tells him that
this is very uncharacteristic of him as
he never just stands in watches from the
sidelines Mikey finally talks like oh my
Lord dude's just been in the most
catatonic State and addresses kakucho as
they face each other prepared to fight
culture declares that he's always wanted
to fight him yo so again we're going to
skip away from the action and head back
over to the other Beatdown as Sinju
stands opposite to South from these
Sidelines Akashi urges senju to stop
telling her that it's too early for her
to face self he adds that he and the
other first generation and black dragon
members would defeat South however since
you shouts back at her brother telling
him to shut his goddamn mouth as she
explains that although she doesn't want
to fight she fears Obama's future as an
organization renting directly in towards
South since you graciously leaps into
the air however just like with the
others her attack is thwarted by South's
punch which redirects her trajectory and
seems with flying back across the ground
seeing this Akashi and takamichi yell
out for her then saying that she started
to bleed they insist that she stop as
there's no way that she can win the
fight to Comey once again pleads for her
to allow brahman's top dogs to continue
fighting alarmed by akashi's statements
takamichi asks what he means exactly
twitch to Comey explains that sinju's
position as one of the three deities
came through the support of the first
generation black dragon members as South
evenly Smiles he approaches Sinju Akashi
begs for her to stop fighting admitting
that he was wrong and he had lost his
call but send you darts in any way with
her eyes closed self prepares his final
blow and until suddenly she opens her
eyes then in a beautiful Display of
Power she realizes that she has been
suppressing her true potential while
quickly dodging underneath self's punch
Sinju uses her forearm as leverage and
quickly delivers a barrage of powerful
text to his face then seemingly floating
in media while constantly kicking South
since you remembers the beginning of
brahman's dealings with corrupt
businesses she saw how his strength
which brought Money Motivated Akashi
worried about her brother's Ambitions
she limited herself to stop him from
taking the wrong path back in reality
now though we see her true strength as
she stands in a glittering fire above an
unconscious self then as per usual we
skip away from the action and find
ourselves in a flashback during the time
that the black dragons were the most
powerful gang in Japan were takomi as
their vice president back then he was
known as the God of War as his technical
decisions always meet the victory of
every battle they were in during
childhood Akashi considered himself
average from his academics to Athletics
and contrast his childhood friend mind
the big shinichiro Sano had a
charismatic quality that seemed to
attract everyone to him which you know
is just like takamichi shinichiro's
kindness was apparent but just like
takamichi he was a fighter who
cried often over time shinichiro's
Charisma extended to his former Rivals
bin K and mukasa then together both gang
leaders along with shinichiro formed the
black dragons were to Comey as their
vice president then as time went forward
through the black dragon's Reign Akashi
sadly became arrogant and drunk on his
Praises till one day he was left
blindsided at shinichiro's decision to
disband the gang shinichiro explained
that their dominance would be akin to
bullying those weaker than them however
takumi just couldn't stop the gang life
and had continued with it with his time
in the black dragons giving him leverage
and power allowing him the Finer Things
in life after five years of living
lavish akashi's influence declined
though leaving him with debts from his
over-expensive lifestyle that kept
piling up five years later in 2006 his
younger sister announces her result
solve to fight the Invincible Mikey from
the prolific tokiomanji gang to do this
Sinju decides to create her own gang bin
Kate and Mikasa who just happen to be
nearby at the time agree as they state
to takomi that his little sister's
strength is no joke then wanting someone
she trusts in the role of seniority
Sinju gives his brother the role
believing him to be someone who can
guide them stunned with his younger
sister's generous offer Akashi has moved
to Tears by the group's faith and
acceptance and Promises to dedicate his
life to the new gang back under the
falling rain now in reality Akashi cries
out to his sister realizing that he
underestimated her strength and lost
sight of brahman's founding ideals her
tributes recruiting dracon as a factor
in losing his sister's trust however
since you disagrees as she says that he
got it all wrong it isn't his fault but
her responsibility and she has failed as
brahman's leader all she can do now is
try and fix the situation and there is
to try and defeat self to which opposite
her South who has just gotten back up
say days that it has been a while since
he's felt this fired up over with
kokucho as he begins fighting Mikey he
lands two strong punches however he is
confused by Mikey's lack of resistance
as he stands there not fighting back
yelling at Mikey could you demands to
know if he's holding back and why he's
even here in the first place escuko
pants from his efforts he looks at Mikey
as if he's punching a ghost although he
takes his hits he doesn't react at all
just then Mikey glances down at his palm
then addressing dracon he says that he
feels empty inside suddenly Darkness
starts growing from behind him and
envelops the entirety of Mikey's Soul
watching in horror kakutra notices a
change occur within Mikey as his dark
compulsitivity fully takes over
meanwhile South in sinju's Fight
Continues with South yelling in Delight
that this is the first time he's felt
this great essenjo skillfully Dodges
South's monstrous punches she lands a
spinning mid ear kick onto his face
however South doesn't stop talking and
screams that he wants this bait to go on
and on unexpectedly his swipe that sends
you in mid-air and connects which seems
to be shooting onto the ground and
coughing up blood having seen this and
yes still just standing in the same
freaking spot takamichi yells out to
send you as she sent herling back a
self-prepares to finish off Sinju he
places his tree trunk of a hand on
takamichi's shoulder and tells him to
move yet the moment South touches
takamichi a vision of himself bending
over self's deceased body flashes
through takamichi's mind back in reality
as South just easily walks past him he's
utterly baffled at the possibility of
South a brutal monster being defeated
and killed just as South as mere steps
away from senju kikuchu slams and skids
onto the ground between them senka
kutchu's bloody and defeated form on the
ground South looks up to find Mikey
facing him so now we finally arrive at
the prime Beatdown material oh my Lord
You're about to witness the Pinnacle of
strength and the humanized world of
Tokyo Avengers so South Chuckles as he
steps towards Mikey no saying it is
finally engaged in the fight watching
the two sends you angrily tells Mikey to
get out of the way herself is her
opponent however Mikey glances at her
with his murderous intent and asks if
she wants to die next stop being sent
you in her tracks south Begins the fight
rushing towards Mikey will they punch
and screaming at him to begin the
requiems finale which you know for those
who have been confused about this whole
like Requiem stuff or the music stuff
South brings up he's referring
specifically here to Mozart's
Masterpiece called the Requiem in D
Minor which is like an absolute Banger
you should all go and listen to that
Mozart didn't actually even get to
complete and like this slaps dude
it goes too hard goes too hard in fact
itself throws his monstrous punch with
Mikey initiating South's Requiem and
kicking him in the jaw as the pair
continues striking each other
simultaneously continuously Landing blow
after blow self lightly proclaims that
the beat down as Unstoppable and is
utterly delighted at finding a nearly
equal opponent however they are
surprisingly interrupted when takamichi
who was finally moved places his box bag
of a body in between the two screaming
at him takamichi tearfully played for
Mikey to stop believing that if this
beat down continues South will
undoubtedly die as a result Mikey who's
just barely injured tells self that
they'll like each other and that they
both can't stop destroying things and in
that moment South finally realizes that
he cannot move his body as he's
immobilized Senate exactly where he is
Mikey then tells self that he's the
exact same as him and that's why he's
here to murder him as he watches
takamichi recognizes that this is
exactly like when Mighty confronted
casatora on Bloody Halloween he tears up
as he realizes that Mikey has truly
become a cold-blooded murderer
approaching Mikey like a complete demon
calmly places his hand on takamichi's
arm and says he is in the way then in a
swift motion he breaks takamichi's elbow
over his knee and drops him to the floor
as takamichi arrives on the ground in
pain Mikey simply walks past him towards
self asking how he wants to die still on
the ground takamichi at the top of his
line screams at Mikey to stop and not do
it however Maki just does not listen as
he proceeds with a downpour of punches
to South's prone body he continues to
literally bait him to death and only
when stealth stops breathing does he
finally step away from the corpse
takamichi tears up as he realizes self's
actually dead and Mikey's Newfound
status is a killer with the gravity of
the situation Dawning on them everyone
around him looks on and pure horror
initially horrified with Mikey's actions
Coco then quickly declares they're both
Sinju and South have lost to Mikey and
that the Kanto Manji gang is victorious
in The Showdown of the three deities he
orders everyone including all of the
boys from the rohuhada tandai and
Brahman to retreat with their injured as
ran helps kakucho leave kakucho wonders
about South's condition ran sadly
responds dismissively adding the South's
absence will be better for them still in
his knees Akashi chastises the extremity
of Mikey's actions but in response they
called kalas Mikey kicks takomi in the
face and threatens his life as well
however before he could continue on his
Beatdown takamichi holding his messed up
arm puts himself between the two and
once again pleads for Mikey to stop
telling him that this is wrong seemingly
bored and sick of this pathetic peasant
Mikey punches takamichi with his full
force directly to his Dome throwing him
across the parking lot and leaving him
helpless behind him an alarmed Coco who
realizes the severity of the situation
pleads for his captain to stop and
Retreat for now not listening though and
being fully enveloped in his Darkness
Mikey ignores Coco's please as he's
still fixated on takamichi who groans
for the pain of the previous punch
standing over him Mahi asks how he wants
his previous best friend to die in lifts
takamishi's limp body up by the collar
which causes our boy to remember the day
Mikey jokingly threatened his life in
the past takamichi though begins to cry
as he realizes that this time he isn't
Kareem from these Sidelines completely
helpless since you watch watches as
Mikey continues to bait takamichi over
and over and over and over and over
again as Mikey brings takameshi to the
ground to strike him since you shout out
screaming his name and with his face
swollen and bloodied takamichi murmurs
Mikey's name as Mikey prepares the final
blow as Mikey sends his final blow
takamichi goes to say his name but loses
Consciousness and has his vision turned
completely black opening his eyes we
find takamichi waking up in the hospital
with severe injuries and his neck arm
face and he's even been put on a
breathing system surprisingly he finds
Coco in his room who informs takamichi
that he remained unconscious for three
entire days following the Battle of the
three deities when takamuchi wonders how
he's alive cuckoo explains that Sinju
saved him and bow to Mikey begging to
end the conflict by little new disband
Brahmin itself the battle of the three
deities concluded with the deaths of
draken and South torano the merging of
the rokuhata tandai and Kanto manjikang
and the disillusion of Brahman Coco then
leaves takamichi to try and process the
battle's outcome before falling back
into unconsciousness takamichi Ponder
sends you sacrifice Mikey's deadly
change from the person he once knew and
finally he wonders what the hell he's
even doing when takamichi wakes up again
he finds shifuyu beside him who tells
him he went to dragon's funeral in tears
Shifu shows just how young he truly is
and questions takamichi asking what's
wrong with them he met with dragon in
the future so why is he dead now Shifu
asks why takamichi came back if the
future was going well for everyone
furiously grief stricken he shouts
almost blaming takamichi for draken's
death but stop short grabbing his mouth
and instead apologizing to takamichi for
his Outburst however our boy agrees with
him and says that it's all his fault he
then asks Shifu to leave him alone to
which he agrees but as he walks away
still in tears shifuyu bids takamichi a
quick recovery so that he can beat him
up himself outside of takamichi's
hospital room she you encounters heiner
who's just gotten back from changing out
takamichi's flowers she remarks on
shifu's short visit confused by his
behavior entering the room again
takamichi apologizes to shifuyu vowing
not to get anyone else ever involved in
his goals again as this is a battle of
his own skipping forward now to the 15th
of July 2008 one week after the
conclusion of the battle of the three
deities takamichi's friends found a miso
middle crew visit his mummified ass in
the hospital alongside heena who let the
go to girl shears has always been by his
side the entire time caring for him as
they leave after trying to reassure him
takamichi thanks them with a pain smile
noticing takameshi's subdued demeanor
Hina asks if anything's wrong to which
he quickly dismisses her worries after
Hina leaves for the store takumichi
mumbles to himself and comprehensibly in
a sort of panic over the true
realization of this situation back in
the hospital other former Tom and
members visit takamichi they all offer
their condolences adding that they
regret not knowing about the bird in
takamichi was carrying around around
with him taking a hold of takamichi's
rusts peon promises that takamiji can
count on them and use the help of need
be taking this in takamichi thanks them
with a smile but reassures them all that
he's fine as the group now begins to
leave takamichi vows to himself not to
get any more former Toman members
involved repeating his goal of
protecting everyone which makes so much
sense to me especially after what
happened with our boy dracon earlier in
the arc like imagine the emotional
damage it would do to her boy's Soul if
he lost three or four other you know
original Tobin members due to end up
with his own dark impulses if it happens
too much skipping back to it henna
finally returns back from shopping and
is surprised to see takamichi's friends
were only there momentarily she tells
him that they visited a bunch while he
was unconscious adding that takamichi is
lucky to have such great friends to
which takamichi like the forward man he
is replies by telling Hina of his
decision to fulfill his mission alone he
says he feels guilt for his selfish
actions that upset all of his friends
then including Hina and this group of
people he tells her that she can go home
as now he will be fine hugging him
though heinous says he is lying and
tells him to cry to which aduba haste
takamichi becomes uncontrollably sobbing
in her arms
so that officially brings us to the very
end of what is Tokyo Avengers three
deities Arc or the first half of it I
guess if you want to say that but I feel
like this is more or less its own arc is
this stuff with a three deities kind of
ends here and it moves back in towards
more of the Mikey in takamichi side of
his story which is the you know like
focal point of the majority of the story
anyway so it's kind of it was kind of
nice slipping away from you know like
the main character but takamichi for a
little bit and meeting all of these new
people throughout the world they're
talking about she now has to add into
his equation of like what am I going to
do to be able to save Mikey with all
these new people around me have I made
the wrong decision with coming back now
and trying to save Mikey like what am I
even doing here and I'm actually going
through like in an entire like belt of
emotions that he hasn't actually had to
deal with before in this series like
completely and utterly doubting himself
on what he actually wants to do like we
saw right at the very end of this part
of the arc right here obviously I think
this part of the series isn't the
strongest like personally speaking I'm
not a real big fan of this and the final
final Arc obviously I love this series
up the first 200 chapters and I think
it's freaking brilliant up to that point
and I really wish there was a way that
everything could have wrapped itself up
right then and there but obviously there
wasn't and this Series has continued on
I can't do anything about that all I can
really say is just that I'm not a huge
fan of this final like Saga in general
and just the way things have been
explained with Mikey's dark impulses and
how who happens to be the time traveler
and stuff like that I just I just really
didn't like the outcome of this story
but that's personally me I'd love to
know what you guys all thought down in
the comment section below and if you are
new around here and want to watch more
stuff just like this where I go over
arcs fights or just pretty much anything
from anime and manga then make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my stuff
to a bunch of new amazing people but
anyway enough of that for now it's been
your professional engineer at diabolo
and I'll see you all a neighbor bye